i am
setting something up for you the head is
just cut
off i'm doing a q a you're gonna do such
a good job you're funny and you're fun
and you're
awesome and you're the best i just want
to make map videos
all right let's do it i've got lots of
just
images look at all these images one of
my
big favorite things to do in my whole
life
is to just surround myself with
visual cues and markers that like remind
me of good
things usually memories i
am a little obsessed with documenting
and then like forcing myself to like
be inundated with all those things like
this cool picture of
a boat i took this on a film camera and
it is a boat
going around a lake in italy me and izzy
when we were first getting started
in our studio my child out of focus one
of my favorite villages in the world in
switzerland
switzerland switzerland and then this
big boy
this is a beach in portugal and henry
right there just good moment the other
thing i do is
maps wait this guy likes maps i found
this old
national geographic switzerland austria
italy i mean does it get any better one
thing i like to do with these old maps
is
look at the stroke of the lines here and
like
how the style of them you'll see on this
that they have a thick
line and then they have sort of like a
feathered off thinner line at all the
borders
and it gives it this glowy effect that's
like really elegant it's just beautiful
here's a map of africa in 1860 looks
very different
maybe i should make a video called how
europe stole africa
anyway i'm just hanging photos and
thinking about the studio and
how it's changing and we've been here
about a year and a half now it's been
great all right
hi everyone i'm not making map videos
today while i am
over there but i'm taking a moment out
to answer some of your questions
because i get a lot of questions and i
feel like every once in a while it's a
good idea to come here and just like
answer all of those questions
let's do it what is your current
favorite breakfast
man breakfast i have a whole new
breakfast life now and it is wonderful
i have started to eat
yogurt and granola uh is made granola
look she made this granola and i've
never really been into granola but then
she made
this and it's like excellent so i've
been eating that i've been eating a lot
of salmon
and rice though i find that i can't do
that every single day i have to sort of
pace it out a little bit you just can't
have salmon every single day i mean
some people can but i've also been
getting like instant soup cups
and putting boiling water in and then
cracking an egg
and then cutting up some avocado and
eating that for breakfast
i guess like the theme here is i just
like savory things for breakfast what is
your favorite
border region in the world that's a
tough question
man i don't know about favorite but at
least like the most
engaging or like the place i think about
the most is the border of
china and nepal it is just
up there in the high mountains and it is
one of the wildest weirdest places i've
ever been on up on the
tibetan plateau so it's very flat but
you're really really high up
um it just has a special culture to it
it's very remote it takes forever to get
up there it's a pretty magical place you
should explore this on a map it's really
interesting to look at this landscape on
a map if you
look up a place called lomantan in
northern nepal
you will see a wonderful place um are
there any cultures your children have
naturally gravitated towards
yes actually yes so for those who don't
know
we used to travel a lot with our
children obviously we don't travel right
now with our children because no one
travels but we've taken them all over
the place i think they've been to like
10 countries and for context
i hadn't left the united states until
like i was a full-fledged adult like i
didn't start traveling so like my
children
at the age of like three had been to
more countries than i had by the time i
was like 25.
our youngest oliver who's four years old
loves japan
he loves japan he loves the robots he
loves the noodles he loves udon
noodles like big long squishy noodles he
loves the trains and we went to like a
like a kids like theme park roller
coaster thing in tokyo and he just like
fell in love he just loves japan oh and
his favorite food is teriyaki chicken
which he he calls it teriyaki chicken
i want teddy yucky chicken it's so cute
melt my heart my
other son henry who is seven loves
trains trains trains trains he's
obsessed with trains
he knows all about trains and he
therefore is really into switzerland
switzerland
yes so now there are two of us in the
family who love
switzerland so japan and switzerland two
places
i'm very happy my boys love oliver also
by the way uses chopsticks like he like
i got him some like chopsticks they're
both left-handed so we got into like
left-handed chopsticks
and he is just so cute with those i love
it
keep going here more questions more
questions
do you ever feel like what you're doing
is not enough
if so how do you cope with that
whoa yeah 100 i definitely feel like
what i'm doing is not
enough always and i think i'm not
unique in that i'm pretty sure human
beings are
programmed to constantly feel like they
need to be doing
more i think it's probably a survival
thing built into our
software uh where we feel like unless we
are
maximizing everything to like earn or
do all the things we're not like
protecting our
uh tribe i don't know i don't know how
it works
like evolutionarily but the fact of the
matter is
even when i'm having success even when i
am
uh being super effective
and fruitful in my work i still feel
this sense of i need to be doing more
i'm constantly not doing enough and i
think our economy
has optimized for that like we're
constantly pushing humans to like
the maximum we can get from them in a
five-day workweek
and it sucks it sucks because i know
that
like i know it in my mind but yeah i
still can't
counteract that and say like it's enough
things are good i'm working on that i'm
working on sort of rewriting that that
software in my brain
to think differently about what i need
to be
doing okay what else do you have plans
to travel to the philippines
yes philippines philippines
like i want to go there so bad on bright
trip we're talking about a course in
manila
with a creator who's there and it's just
getting me like really excited
uh about the notion of
traveling to the philippines someday
where do you learn to edit like you
i learned to edit over many many years
just
practicing that being said on bright
trip i think
we're probably gonna eventually do a
course that's like professional
post-production
fundamentals and it'll be me teaching
everything i know about basic animation
and editing and storytelling in a
post-production standpoint so
we have camera fundamentals now and i
i think we're probably going to push a
more in-depth
shooting fundamentals and then
post-production fundamentals it's part
of this broader goal i have to sort of
teach
everything i know about this craft
including journalism and storytelling
and research and writing
all of that um on bright trip not gonna
be doing that tomorrow but
that is in the works and you can always
sign up for the bright trip newsletter
if you want to sort of be informed on
that you also get 20 off your first
course purchase if you
sign up for that newsletter so probably
an important
thing to think about okay tell us about
your education
okay i'll make this quick i have a
bachelor's degree in international
relations i have a master's degree
in international peace and conflict
resolution from american university here
in washington dc
both of those were decisions i made to
invest
in my what i call soft skills my
thinking skills
my data skills my research skills
my sort of argumentative and writing
skills
i don't think it was completely
necessary meaning i don't think
i still think i could do interesting
work without
having gone to college but college gave
me some useful academic skills that i
use in all the videos i make
what would you say to somebody who wants
to start
creating video but doesn't know where to
start or
what to share this is a tough question
to ask because i only have my experience
to go off of
like i started making video really young
and just never stopped and so i don't
have
super clear perspective on your specific
situation that being said i know a few
key things that
i think apply to everyone which is
number one the only way to
improve is to just start making things
and to make a lot of things you have to
get a large volume
of work under your belt before you start
to really see
the results you want i mean that's not a
novel idea but
i think it's important to just say you
have to start somewhere
you have to start where to start um so
here's a quick start guide on
where to begin with video find a video
that you like
what is a video that you like that is
really interesting to you and you're
like i want to make something like that
and then emulate it copy it
copy it but copy just some of the
elements of it the format maybe the
music
don't try to copy it exactly but try to
use it as inspiration
and to dissect it and say why is this
video good why do i like it
and start to emulate that word is really
important
you have to emulate if you're going to
create your own stuff i emulated
a lot of people sort of like
taking inspiration from how people did
things and that's how i found my own
voice pick a topic that you like
and then pick a video that you like the
format of and then emulate it
and start to make something and it's not
going to be good at first it's just not
it's going to take a while before your
videos start to look good that's the
journey we all went through all right
here is a question i get a lot i'm
excited to
talk about it which is how do i find and
research
topics for my videos the answer is i
choose the topic of videos based on what
i'm genuinely interested
in genuinely curious about these videos
take a really long time they take a lot
of effort
and if i'm not like passionately into it
then
i'm gonna lose steam pretty quickly so i
will often be reading books that
are sort of topics i'm interested in
like
international affairs or middle eastern
politics or
um i don't know like the history of the
india partition and i will find bits
within that where i'm like wow
that is fascinating to me and as soon as
i have that i will then start to
dive in on reading wikipedia articles
wikipedia
is like my best friend because wikipedia
gives me
the building blocks i need to construct
the videos i make often books
and things like that have like the key
details that are like really really
interesting
but wikipedia gives me the context and
the broader story
of what it is i'm researching and i'm
really grateful for wikipedia anyone who
bad mouse wikipedia
i'm in a bad mouth you yep all right
what is the brand of the leather boots
that i'm wearing all the time
these leather boots so here's a story i
destroy
shoes i'm a person who destroys shoes
not for fun not because i want to but
because i walk in this really
intense way that destroys all footwear
anything in front of my feet
just gets destroyed so i kind of started
to get into boots and realized that
after about
11 months my boots would start to like
just fall apart
the sole would start to fall off the
threading would start to
sort of disintegrate and i got tired of
it a couple years ago and i said like
there has to be a boot in this world
that can like withstand
my intense walk and sure enough i went
into a boot store
in portland oregon of all places the
perfect place for this
and i asked them and they're like we
have the boot for you
and they introduced me to a genre of
boot
that was invented by
several companies back in like the 40s
at the behest of the united states
government who had
like jail inmates that needed
a pair of boots that the government
didn't want to replace every
few years they wanted a boot that would
last them like 30 years
for these inmates have gotten into this
boot by wolverine
called 5 000 mile boot
okay i'm done talking about boots i've
been talking about boots way too long
that was a deeper rabbit hole than i
expected to get into what is your blood
type
what is the best technique for becoming
fluent in spanish
man same advice that i would give
to someone wanting to learn video you
have to immerse yourself
in doing it like there's no way
especially with a language
other than uh immersion here's my
analogy ready
a classroom spanish or classroom
language learning
is like learning knife skills if you
want to cook
you're like okay i can learn how to
chop a carrot and you're chopping
carrots all day you're like i'm getting
really good at chopping carrots and then
you're like oh but i don't know how to
cook
and they're like yeah because you need
to actually go into the kitchen and put
the carrots in a
pot of olive oil and then you need to
put celery in and blah blah and you're
like no no i'm just gonna be here and
chop and like chop all day and i'm gonna
get really good at it it's like no
you're just learning how to chop
you're not learning how to cook like go
cook going to a country
and feeling the discomfort of immersion
and
not being able to communicate is like
cooking it's not just like learning how
to chop
i'm kind of proud of that little
metaphor i'm gonna like file that away
and use that
more and more do you have any plans
about making videos about
india's partition come on
really i spent half of my 2019 making
videos
about india and one specifically about
the partition
just type in vox borders india
and you will see it can you make a video
about puerto rico
yes totally on the list totally come in
man what a wild history what a wild
situation
puerto rico i got you favorite color
green i don't know it just depends on
the context but
green is there going to be a bright trip
app in the future
yes definitely i have an interest in
maps
and about countries like you do but i
have no idea what to do with that
interest
the answer is to just dig in
we have the internet for heaven's sake
like we have
every bit of information we could ever
want
and it just requires a little bit of
searching if you're interested in maps
go to
the library of congress map room on the
internet
and look at the beautiful high-res maps
that they have go to the david
rumsey collection and look at their old
maps
you need to cultivate that curiosity and
luckily you have
the world at your fingertips via the
internet what's a good starter camera
for travel man
we just made a course on how to document
your travels and i did it all
on my iphone more and more it's becoming
obsolete what camera you have it comes
down to
how you stabilize it and what kinds of
shots you get like this thing
it's got three lenses on it a wide angle
let's get everything i need
i use this more and more i used to hate
when people would say that when i was
first getting into this like they'd be
like yeah it doesn't matter the gear
i'm like yeah it does better camera i'm
getting more and more into that
uh that gear isn't the most important
thing but i hate it when people say that
to me so i'm not gonna say it to you
even though i just did
sorry i'm getting a lot of questions
about vox
and borders and i will tell you this
i will have a very clear update on all
of that
in the next two to three weeks that is a
promise
i will give you all the information that
i know you will know
in two to three weeks any book
recommendations
oh man i just finished this book
educated it was incredible
just a really incredible story how are
you handling staying in one place for so
long
this has been really interesting i'll
put it that way it's been
really good in some ways and really
difficult in other ways
first off we have it pretty darn good we
have our studio and office space here
in all of the covid situations we have a
pretty darn good setup and i'm grateful
for that that being said
this is a pandemic and our children
aren't going to be in school this fall
and we're trying to figure out
homeschool
and it's just stressful and of course we
you know our business
relies on travel and so we've had to
pivot and there's been some complication
to it but
amongst all of us there has been a
certain quiet and routine
settled on our family that has been new
for us and it's been
healthy and and good and good
perspective what it's doing actually is
instilling a new
appreciation for travel travel is such a
resource intensive
thing such a privilege and i
feel like it was getting really normal
and i feel like now i'm i'm
re-cultivating that perspective that
like oh wow flying on a plane across the
entire world is a big deal
i should appreciate that a little bit
more so i think that's a really good
outcome for those
probably for a lot of people what are
some things that are on your bucket list
i don't actually have a real bucket list
but i do have some things swirling
around my brain that i would probably
put on this which is i want to
extensively
hike in the mountains of switzerland
just like go on hikes
camp see beautiful peaks find some
bunkers for those who don't know what
i'm referring to go
watch my switzerland video about bunkers
in the middle of the swiss countryside
it's like my heaven one thing that's
really exciting for me is to go on a
trip with my
like teenage or adult children like once
my kids are grown up like i'm really
excited to
go on even a quiet like fishing trip
down the road just to have that
experience i think will be really
wonderful i want to learn another
language
in my lifetime um right now i speak
spanish and
i have a conversational understanding of
french and study a little bit of farsi
as well but i want to be
very fluent in another language i love
italian
italian is a language that i would maybe
want to bite off as like a fourth
language to learn
i've always wanted and this is kind of a
far-flung dream
but like a big dream of mine someday is
to live in a small town
in france and to
solidify my french and work in a bakery
i love bread it would just be a coming
together of so many of my
interests to do something like that
obviously it's not the time of life
like you know i i'm in this other mode
of building a family building a life
here in this washington dc area but
maybe someday in the future what is your
favorite episode of borders
this changes all the time maybe the hong
kong
episode one and two together because
they're kind of like one big episode
split into two
basically how the british took over hong
kong and then how it was given back and
now how china is trying to take over
hong kong reporting that story
was really impactful for me i learned a
lot i met a lot of amazing people i went
to some
wild places i just really immersed
myself in that story loved your
astrophotography
journey do you plan on continuing the
hobby yes
i plan to we shall see where i go in it
i'm sort of taking a break
because it takes a bit of a toll on like
when we're out
i sort of like obsessed with it and is
sort of like dude
can you like just be here speak of the
devil oh
can't buy something like this and just
like not
keep up with okay i mean i didn't make a
video about it really just our
entire studio anyway so this gives you
an idea of where we're at with
astrophotography
how do you script your videos uh do you
include direction on motion graphics yes
in fact
i share all the scripts to my videos on
patreon so
if you go to patreon.com johnny harris
there is one tier where i share
all of my scripts and you can see
exactly
how i script my videos the short answer
is yes i script every word
every bit of visual direction i have
scripted on paper before i even delve in
okay
so those are my questions uh answered
today
thank you audible for sponsoring this
video audible i mean
speaking of reading books and doing
journalism audible is the place where i
listen to so
many books i just love audible audible
is basically just a giant repository of
audiobooks
that you can purchase and listen to i'm
listening to this audiobook called why
we're polarized by ezra klein who's the
founder of box it's about
polarization in american politics and it
is so timely
and important right now if you're
following american politics what i love
about audible
is that it's a subscription so you pay a
monthly price
it's like less than 15 bucks a month and
you get
any audio book in their huge repository
for that same price one a month you can
get you can pick out an audio book no
matter how expensive or cheap it is you
pay the same price
you also get access to audible's
original content
which is stuff that audible makes it's
only on audible audio stuff that you can
listen
to and it's great so i love audible i
love the interface i love the user
experience
i've been using audible well before they
ever came to sponsor a video
because i'm dyslexic so reading for me
is hard
and i'm busy and so audible has changed
my world you can get a free book
if you want to try this out if you go to
my link in the description clicking that
link helps support this video
and more importantly it gives you a free
book and access to
these audible originals which are really
great high quality productions thank you
audible for supporting this channel
thank you all for watching
i have some really awesome videos lined
up for the next couple of weeks
so get ready for those youtube's fun i'm
enjoying being here and sharing these
videos and
lots more to come thank you all for the
questions that you asked have a great
day
see you later